let me tell you about the 2018 Honda
Accord the sophisticated interior and
UPS the upscale styling you could say
it's unexpected certainly since I drove
the Honda Accord for my first job around
upstate New York looking for my first TV
gig and it looks nothing like the Honda
Accord that you will see at your local
Honda dealer right now that a court is
calling its most impressive Honda to
date and then inside the sophisticated
interior the leather shift knob
ventilated front seats available leather
heated and ventilated front seats the
leather wrapped steering wheel the
standard dual zone climate control that
wasn't in my on d'accord anything in the
Honda cores a tape deck that's what it
taped and my own my own alarm system
that I was able to put in there
everything is incredible the wireless
trim standard on all trim is the
standard Honda sensing as well that
helps you to keep you safe from points A
to B so check out the new Accord at your
local Honda dealer that was actually my
mom's first car our our first car was a
Honda Accord that was a station wagon
estate but it also had a cassette player
what was what were you listening to um
I'm always always listen to like like
Earth Wind and Fire now that's something
else yeah she she was always waiting for
ya so those like all my fondest memories
is going to school and this RIT is a red
station wagon register Rich Eisen show
good to see you thank you very so what's
going on with you let's talk about this
then we'll move on a football and other
stuff and obviously your charity weekend
I want to get a whole bunch of people
interested in raising funds yeah having
a good time with you yeah so you sued
the Los Angeles Rams well they were the
st. Louis Rams at the time you sued the
Rams yes okay because why also if you
saw the play the slip-and-fall that I
had in 2015 November 1st
you know I slipped and fell on concrete
as you're watching right here and you
know I'd never seen concrete before in a
stadium that close to you
to a football field and so ended up
tearing my lateral meniscus and in my
season and I subsequently really ended
my career because as you and as you know
and understand in our in our league at
the professional level
perception is reality and a lot of the
times the perception is that when a
player has a significant injury he will
not come back to be the same athlete as
he was before so I went to Buffalo
I signed a Miss for agency period signed
in August and you know I was really
promised a lot by Rex Ryan and the
Buffalo Bills and the GM at the time
they wanted me to split time with shady
kind of to take some of the load off of
him to keep him fresh throughout the
season Carlos Williams I was suspended
and they didn't think he was gonna be
available that season which he ended up
not being so I was the number two guy
and he also wanted me return punts and
do some stuff as a receiver as well
after week three our officer pointer got
fired
it was Giro and then as you know Rex
Ryan got fired as well throughout the
season so whatever I was promised just
went out the door somehow someway I
never got on the field never really got
a chance to see the field they never
used me not literally sat on the bench
so if you had gotten the chance that you
thought you deserved in Buffalo if
you're still sued the Rams I don't know
I'm not sure because for one there
should never be concrete surface next to
a football field when you have football
players playing with cleats and it's
extremely slippery it just doesn't make
sense to me so stuff like that you know
we have enough to worry about why I say
we I'm not playing anymore but you know
the players have enough to worry about
you know on the field within the lines
and and when you have stuff like that
that makes the game that's already
dangerous even that more dangerous and
um you know that's that's not okay
because player safety should be first
and foremost so the judge ordered the
Rams to pay you twelve almost twelve and
a half the jury likes the jury did the
jury deserted so ladies and gentlemen it
was a jury trial and everything yeah it
was a jury trial okay we never thought
it was gonna make it to trial you know
they obviously saw a different we
actually wanted to settle out of court
and this is what's crazy you know I'm
gonna believe this
the judge during a trial recommended to
them that they should sell the court our
attorneys their attorneys told them
whoever the insurance adjuster was just
they said that we would never pay you
more than a million dollars so I was hit
for a million dollars you can just keep
that I'll rather try it and see what
happens so two days before the final
verdict we were in negotiations to sell
out of court I asked for I said the
lowest I would go is 3.7 they said I
will never pay you anything that starts
with a 2 or 3 and I said ok how about
four did you say that isn't an answer
man 2 or 3 them so I was like all right
if the judge tells you you should settle
out of court then you know what I mean
so now there's a 12 in front of it where
does it stand then I mean are you gonna
get a check you think oh yeah I'm gonna
get something no I'm getting a check for
sure okay so are they where does it
stand are they appealing or something
like that
they'll probably appeal but you know in
order for two to appeal you have to have
you know grounds to appeal and in this
case I mean it's pretty straightforward
there's there's 12 15 different camera
angles I saw my slip and fall on a
concrete so what are you appealing you
know what I mean Reggie Bush here on the
Rich Eisen show all right let's take a
break we're gonna take a 60-second break
come back I want to talk to you about
some football sir
Lamar Jackson this is a fascinating to
me me too how it's laying out in
Baltimore yeah
two quarterbacks set is kind of what
you're calling it right now which is
fascinating to me how that's all playing
out I want to get your two cents on that
also talk about the Reggie Bush charity
weekend as well okay that's so with
Reggie Bush and by the way you also I
think we're gonna do this with Reggie
okay you know cuz it's a Friday a fun
Friday into the weekend yes no we have a
competition that we frequently do here
love comfort okay well I think when
you're gonna be you're gonna be I think
the phone a friend in this okay I'm
going to say the name of either a player
that's participating in the World Cup or
it's the name of a pharmaceutical that
you can get and it's called player of
pharmaceutical these guys are gonna try
and guess which one and you will be sort
of the lifeline okay help okay Reggie
Bush there's gonna be a lot of fun at
Reggie Bush on Twitter Reggie Bush back
here on the Rich Eisen show on 60 cents
[Music]
all right Reggie Bush is back here on
the Rich Eisen show and always great to
see you man oh it's great to see you
so the Reggie Bush charity weekend let's
get to that black-tie dinner and a
comedy show that's on Friday yes okay
also part of the dinner oh it's all yes
okay yeah a golf tournament in a VIP
party on Saturday yes and it's in San
Diego California and you go to Reggie
Bush org to get tickets hmm yes and
that's on the 22nd and 23rd so next
weekend yeah we had a good group of guys
coming out Toro was gonna be there who's
also recently been in news so he's
coming he's coming he's coming
yes coming yes okay what's the party
situation
[Applause]
yeah ask you 4000k might be where he
celebrates what do you think of that you
know I would've liked to have seen me
being a fan of tio I would've liked to
have seen him go to the Hall of Fame and
put aside whatever built up you know
aggression or whatever built-up
resentment he may have towards people or
towards the Hall of Fame and really just
enjoy the moment for what it is because
I understand that maybe he probably
should have been the first ballot right
and when you marry when you look at that
versus other players I got in the first
ballot I would have liked to have seen
tio
go there and accept the Hall of Fame
speech just because I'm a fan and as a
fan I want to see one of the best
receivers of all time go and you know
see his statue get enshrined you know do
the whole deal man I thought that
would've been special yeah I don't think
it's gonna happen I don't know I don't
know course knowing tio is he's serious
about what he said Landon Donovan gonna
be there - Ronnie long I love ya man
David Justice mm-hmm yeah and so how and
this is in support of the fountain your
foundation or Dennis Haysbert it's gonna
be there
he was just here last week was he yeah
he was nice rugged all for - I know
golf with him but yeah we got some we
had a good group of people that's coming
out it's gonna be fun
Reggie Bush tour get tickets going to
hang out with everybody right there
Lamar Jackson how good do you think he
can be I think skies are the limits I
think you know I think he has the
obviously the athleticism is the one
thing that jumps out at you right away
but if he can become a mature pocket
passer that's dangerous because you
match the athleticism of him with you
know being that pocket passer and and I
talked about this yesterday because you
know for quarterbacks for that athletic
and who take off and run as you know at
the professional level it's only a
matter of time before you get injured
right and you look at Carson Wentz the
group is a great of a season he was
having last year you know it just took
that one time for him to take off and
run and you know he was out for the rest
of season you know I thought Russel
Wilson has done a great job because he
gets down right does he gets down yeah
and and so if if the Marg axon can can
you know understand that aspect of
running that you have to get down and
live to fight another day and then
become this really really mature pocket
passer he's gonna be special well in
order to do that you've got to get the
reps you know to be the starter yeah
yeah to get the reps pretty much so I
don't know how that's going to work in
2018 because this offense needs to have
that kid on a fee they do period end of
story
so what do you think of this two
quarterbacks set idea that they're
talking about things gonna work I think
there's already bad blood when you
drafted them especially for Flacco so I
don't think it's gonna work because you
know that when he gets in a game it's
going to be you know this option read
deal and what if he starts to do really
well then what does that say for Flacco
you know how does that affect him in his
playing time so we've never seen that
happen at this level we've always seen
at the college level and I just I don't
think it's gonna work so I mean even if
Flacco takes the
snap the shotgun we'll just say that
alright and Lamar Jackson is standing to
his right yeah there apparently want to
call that a two quarterback set don't
call him a running back even though they
might flip on the ball and on occasion
maybe he'll throw out of that I mean
yeah that's the idea is that maybe just
maybe they're gonna have some idea that
that Lamar will throw out of all of that
but like Antwon Randall L you know some
whacked-out stuff might come out of
Baltimore this fall yeah but then you're
putting him at risk because if if he
takes off and runs now you're putting
your first-round jafek at risk of injury
all right or you get a touchdown or a
first down where you get a touchdown but
that's the risk/reward right like what
and you have to play the percentages of
the risk/reward like what's more
important is it more important for us to
give Lamar Jackson ability to be on the
field and risk him getting injured by
running him and or do we want him to
start to mature as his pocket passer to
develop for later on because later on
what's more important is that the
longevity is it you know the the next 10
years the 10 year plan for Lamar Jackson
or is it right now let's get him on the
field and use his athleticism and then
you you know then you know what the
risks are then let's let's get him to a
little bit of real talk then because you
know what it's like to be in a practice
you know what it's like to be in a
locker room yeah let's say that Lamar
starts doing stuff on that practice
field he's already done it maybe this
week in training camp yeah he's doing it
then yeah and then out comes Joe taking
his reps and it's just the usual offense
without Lamar on the field yeah do you
guys talk to each other and start saying
what's going on for of course they do
and listen if if Joe Flacco doesn't play
well and he's had some struggles these
last few years I think to say the least
and then Lamar Jackson starts to show
signs and you know that there's already
the writings kind of our already on the
wall mm-hm but you know if Flacco starts
to struggle a lot you know I think we
can definitely see Lamar Jackson a lot
earlier than we were expecting Reggie
Bush here a couple more with you what do
you think do you think levy on bail
knees should be paid like a wide
receiver
I think llave young bill should get paid
as a playmaker and I don't know because
there is no category for playmakers so
you know
having been through this I know what
Baltimore's trying to do to him they
only want to pay him running back market
value give me the steal there's
obviously I mean no no we were just talk
but he's more than that he counts for
49% of that offense you know so it's and
turn around and it's late on bill
and that's it so they want to pay him as
a running back market value even though
he splits out wide and he plays receiver
um he does it all for them you know so
unfortunately because we don't have
guaranteed contracts until we get those
you know it's the players don't have as
much leverage but I think he should get
paid as a athlete you know running back
and receiver and I don't know how that
works out when the numbers on the
business side but you know I had the
same issues you know when I was playing
for you know the Saints and because I
was used in a lot of different ways so I
wanted to be paid like I was using a lot
of different ways and not just paid as
strictly a running back not box into
this category how'd that work out for
you they didn't work out
I got rated I think it's gonna work out
with Ingram in New Orleans right now
well I know he wants a new deal right
and I know is pretty hard to get a new
deal when you're suspended for four
games you know so I don't know if he's
gonna get that deal I hope he does but
it's not gonna happen before the season
it probably won't happen until after the
season he he will have to prove and show
that you know and play well this year to
get that contract okay Reggie Bush here
Johnson show alright are you ready to
take part I'm ready this new competition
this competition that you've never been
part of before Reggie Bush here on the
Rich Eisen show playing the drum
petition from suit so I'm gonna give a
name Chris Brockman and Mike del Teufel
first two three wins
how about that three yeah first two
three wins and Reggie Bush is here at
anymore even time is there any music
that you can play for this mic though
tufa or normal come on very good I will
name that this is the name of a player
that's participating in this year's
world okay or a pharmaceutical that you
might consult your doctor before taking
okay just Americans in the world coming
unfortunally that it's the entire world
cup Taylor I'm sorry sorry okay here we
go
Prolia Prolia for a circle it's a
treatment for osteoporosis you're
postmenopausal medicine it's a masking
agent for the HDH is it really number
two number two far fan far fan is that a
pharmaceutical or a World Cup player
Mike tell Tufo you can ask you can ask
Reggie Bush for help if you want Reggie
with it is that a player or
pharmaceutical far fan I'm just a player
hi agrees Brockman that's what I was
gonna sell forward for Perot okay here
we go
hey Pavan Pavan Pavan Pavan as a pair of
at Pavan yeah I don't know you ask me
yeah yeah yeah man putting pressure on
me I'm gonna say player you go with
Reggie what are you gonna go Mike I say
player he's a winger for argentinas time
you guys got three each okay could end
in a tie proscar proscar have at it Mike
Mike tell to 4ei Reggie Bush is here to
help proscar Reggie
I don't go with him if he guesses know
what I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
pharmaceutical I think it's a
pharmaceutical Chris god I think so too
it's a treatment
no it's let's keep going Oh hold on let
me put my glasses on for this one this
is Sol la Sol la Sol do I go la Sol la
Sol Brockman's first time for each I'm
gonna say player what do you think Mike
Delta pharmaceutical Lossless the keeper
for dead this is the all-time greatest
additionally pharmaceutical Wow I'll
give him that one that was a I would
have said I would have said player -
yeah we only got through half the list
so we'll do it again I mean you're
already fired up because is it still one
why no Spain scored sets 1 in 1 1 1 and
1 1 nice Portugal right Spain Portugal
do you have a team you have an adopted
team really I would cheer for the
Americans but we're not you have to wait
till 2022 do you want to pick a name out
of a hat and join our contest it's just
the three of us who we picked a name out
of a hat to adopt a team he chose
freakin Argentina del two photos Japan
and I chose Mexico the only issue with
Argentina is they only have Messi and
they never they always rely on his joke
yeah to score all the goal always
choking just like you with our
n-c-double-a tournament basically you're
like the Argentine of the rich fashion
show for for 200 for rich number to dial
Reggie Bush is gonna help me try and
give away flutter when I come back
call right now when we come back on the
television side of things
I've come so close to giving away a
putter I really want to do it before the
end of this show don't go anywhere we're
back with that and more in a moment the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience